[Music]  hello miss June how are you doing Tom  very good good will you look us pay for  the lumberjack pants well you know I  like them yeah so you are looking hot  mama I know right  well dr. Coulter said everything went  great and then in the morning you get to  lose all of these little puppies you  look like a Christmas tree mm-hmm he's  willing more drinks on me this time it's  killing me  June just so you know I spoke to  everybody back in Georgia your family  knows that you are doing great I'm glad  the girls know that I'm okay because I  was worried about them being worried  because it's surgery to it so long now  I'm ultra cover again and Britt is here  to take care of me I just felt the pain  doesn't last as long as it did last time  [Music]  you